welcome what was happening
[Music]
Kylie Jenner gives fans a look at her
blessed mornings with her kiddos and
it's the cutest thing you'll see all day
I'm obsessed with it so on Tuesday the
reality star shared this sweet clip to
Instagram that's Kylie with her
five-year-old daughter stormy and
one-year-old son air lounging in bed
smiling for the camera and just when you
thought it couldn't get more wholesome
stormy tickles her little bro and his
giggle is everything
Kylie captioned the clip blessed
mornings with my babies
of course Kylie shares her kiddos with
her on and off Beau Travis Scott back in
January A source told E.T the two are on
a break explaining that they live at
different Lifestyles and that's been a
big issue with two kids Kylie doesn't go
out too much Travis on the other hand
lives a life of late nights in the
studio and going out with friends
Kylie and Travis were first linked in
2017 and had stormy the year after after
a brief split in 2019 they revved things
back up in 2020 and have been together
ever since welcoming their son air whom
they originally named wolf to the world
last year
I just wasn't him there's only one but
he's already got a flair for style check
out the little guy walking around
Kylie's closet on a mission for some
sweet shades foreign
can I have my glasses back
oh
as for Kylie's love life a source
recently confirmed to E.T that she's
dating Timothy chalamet but the two are
keeping things casual we are told it's
not serious but Kylie's enjoying hanging
out with the Oscar nominee and seeing
where it goes that's what it is to be
young we'll just have to wait and see
how it all plays out but in the meantime
we're counting down the days until the
Kardashians season 3 premieres on Hulu
we have huge influence what are we doing
with our power
and we'll be keeping an eye out for any
possible cameos from Timothy I wish I
could tell you this is going to be a
mild relaxing Serene season
it's not
[Music]